R
THERE SHE .
ELIZABETH MAKING
SURPRISE ANCON BALCONY ATNGHA
YAL
PEANA HUGEREIGN.
RAN LONDON THAUDED
THE S GOLDENE. AYSE
HER WHENHE YOUNG QUEEN.
MA
HOAK HAPPEN? HOLOGRAM OF H ILD
SPOOT IT.THGOLDEN CARRIAGE
E IT WAS O WAS
O.AS IWE PAST, THERE WAS A T
IT WAS WAY IT
LOOSINE  V.
THIS HION FIQUEEN.
HOEEHEN TODAY AFTER
DASHHAS IS HOW
E LOOKED RAVISHING IN GREEN,EME
CTISAS
GIVEN D THE FLAG WAS ABOUTTO SIN
WAS IN
SHTTEND.D IS BOOEN
D THATENT.PEOPAVE OUT EY
S WE WER
EA RECD A NO
TO MEQUEEN,BUT THAT SHE'SMESSAG
HISTOROMENT.EE TO PY PIESMOMENTE
G TO THIS
E PUTS IT, WHEIT MARRS'S NE  FO.
ASTHUO PLE HAVE
LAOW IFR YOU
EA BEEN  Y
AND I REMAIN CO
U T OFITY, SUPPORTED BY ILY.HEAS
E' THICE CHARLESL STEP IN WHENH
THCSECWAR,VID.EARSME.S SPEAKING
K THISS TYPEF
LEADER SHE IS.
EO'SS PRIA.
STI THYO
R SHES THE
RTE
N IS WE
D EXPECTTHIN Q ELIZATH?K U, FOS.
HAV M
THE LASTW S CELEBRATED OACTIONF
SA ONE.
ET THEY
IT WASLA
IT WAS SO PERSONAL.
FOR ME THAT OWG I BONEIT WAS SHU